- [Voiceover] There are
four seasons each year.
Rafael gets a haircut
two times each season.
One at Arlo's barber shop, and
the other at Awesome Snips.
Which choices represent the number
of haircuts Rafael will get this year?
And they've even made a little
diagram for us right over here.
So they tell us there's
four seasons in the year,
Spring, Summer, Autumn, Winter.
And that each season
Rafael gets two haircuts.
He gets one at Arlo's
and one at Awesome Snips.
So in Spring this is
the one that he gets at
Arlo's, this is the one that
he gets at Awesome Snips.
And Summer, this is the
one he gets at Arlos',
this is the one he gets at Awesome Snips.
Autumn this is the he gets at Arlo's,
this is the one at Awesome Snips.
And Winter, this is the one at Arlo's,
So they ask us, which choices represent
the number of haircuts
Rafael will get this year?
Well one way to this about it is:
In Spring he will get two haircuts then
in Summer he is going to
get another 2 haircuts.
In Autumn he is going to
get another two haircuts.
And then in Winter he is going
to get another two haircuts.
So he is going to get two in Spring,
plus two in Summer, plus two in Autumn,
plus two in Winter.
Which is going to be
equal to eight haircuts.
So which of these represent eight?
Well let's see, two plus
two, that's not eight.
Four plus four plus four plus four,
that's not eight, that's 16.
Two plus two is four.
Four plus four is eight, plus four is 12
plus four is 16, that's not eight.
Four plus four, that is equal to eight.
That is the number of haircuts
Rafael is going to get this year.
So we can check that one.
Two plus two plus two plus two,
that's exactly what we
wrote here, and it is eight.
So that is equal to the number
of haircuts he is going to get this year.
And then two plus four, well that's not
equal to eight, that's
six, so that's not right.
So these are the two that represent
the number of haircuts
Rafael will get this year.